hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk you
know people yeah I know you know people
always ask me how much does it cost to
launch a video show how much did it cost
you to build up Wine Library TV there's
a question I'm asked all the time I was
doing an interview today for a business
video blog and once again gallery but
the big question is how much does it
cost to do this and build your brand and
build in the new soapy media world and
here's my answer folks two cents two
cents I spent millions of dollars
building winelibrary.com New York Times
Wall Street Journal full-page has
annoyed spectator billboards radio
star-ledger Direct Mail just on and on
and on why might be TV two cents my two
cents that's what it cost me you need to
get into the community if you are just
starting the show right now or a blog
and you're trying to figure out how to
get traffic here is how you do it let me
help you forget about all the glitz and
glamour
forget about your spinach because it can
be anything what you need to focus on is
your content you have to have the chops
if what you talk about or what you do
sucks
you've lost anyway this next part won't
matter so please even if you're really
passionate about it understand you've
got to be good I'm very passionate
Abby was starting running back for the
New York Jets but it's not going to
happen you don't see me doing a science
blog even though I see huge opportunity
there cuz some of those signs advertiser
just got back you know you've got to
have the chops to that's why I stick to
the beat oh sometimes the sports you
know so recognize that but more
importantly the way you go about is you
pump out the content and then you spend
hours hours eighty to ninety percent of
your time
did you just hear what I said leaving
comments on blogs forums and social
networks that have to do with your
subject matter for example if I was not
at the pinnacle of where I am now
and I saw plenty of that kind of work to
do now but a lot of words now coming to
me but I would be in every Facebook fan
page about my subject
if there was a Facebook fan page for
cabernet and other Merlot's and
otherwise and there's tons of them I be
in there becoming a fan of all of them
and leaving relevant content not saying
oh come and check out my video on this
Merlot no I would just say oh this is
one of my favorite Merlot's and
hopefully some people click my face find
my page and on I would go to every blog
right now I would go in Google Blog
search and type in the word wine like I
did years ago and go in and spend time
reading the most current blog posts from
somebody no matter how big if it's the
649 meters that's huge seven weiners you
don't skip that blog read the latest
posts and leave a contact you know a
comment excuse me you're making a
connection with that blogger and with
that small audience that person has so
you go out there and you start leaving
your two cents and you leave their two
cents everywhere right and so all of a
sudden two cents becomes four cents and
four cents becomes eight cents and eight
cents becomes sixteen cents and before
you know it you've put out a million
dollars and when you put out a million
dollars you're on your way to getting a
million dollars so yeah